مجرمة بزي راهبة،
هي ابنة غير شرعية،
أصبحت قاتلة محترفة، تقتل دون ترك أثر،
كانت تؤمن أن حياتها عبارة عن لعنة،
عاشت طفولة البؤس والشقاء والكدر،
اللعنة انعكست على صديقاتها،
لكن هل صارت مجرمة بملئ إرادتها
، أم أن هنالك أسباب أدت لذلك؟
(عن ليوناردا جنجولي نتحدث وللقصة بقية)
بينما كانت أم ليوناردا في عمر ال١٤ تعرضت لحادثة اغتصاب،
بواسطة أحد رعاة الماشية، وهي عائدة لمنزلها من المرعى عام١٨٩٤
، وعندما ظهرت عليها أعراض الحمل أجبرها والدها على الزواج
من ذلك الشاب، لكن أم ليوناردا لم تكن تراها بعين الأم
بل كانت الطفلة تعيش حياة بائسة جدا،
فأمها لا تراها إلا عبارة عن ابنة حادثة اغتصاب ولا تريدها،
ومازاد الطين بلة، بعد وفاة والدها، تزوجت أمها برجل آخر،
وهنا أصبحت ليوناردا منبوذة تماما،
وكل اهتمام والدتها صبته على إخوة ليوناردا وأخواتها،
فعانت الأمرين من والدتها ودخلت في حالة نفسية كئيبة،
حتى أنها حاولت أن تنتحر شنقا مرتين حينها،
في المرة الأولى أنقذوها في آخر لحظة،
وفي المرة الثانية انقطع الحبل، فقالت لها والدتها عند ذلك
( أنا آسفة حقا أنك مازلت على قيد الحياة)
فلخصت بذلك مقدار كرهها لليوناردا، ولما بلغت سن المراهقة
كانت جنجولي مشهورة بجرأتها وسمعتها السيئة،
وعاشرت العديد من أبناء بلدتها علّها تجد الحب
الذي لم تحصل عليه منذ ولادتها، وفي عام ١٩١٧،
تزوجت جنجولي بموظف حكومي على الرغم من معارضة أهلها لذلك،
لأنهم كانوا يريدون تزويجها بأحد أقاربها الميسورين،
وفي حفل عرسها اقتحمت أمها حفل الزفاف وقالت لها،
(أرجوا أن يموت جميع أطفالك)،
فاعتبرت تلك الدعوة من أمها لعنة طاردتها طول حياتها
(اللعنة والإجرام)
بعد زواجها لم تحسن جنجولي من سلوكها بل زادت شراسة
وتم حبسها مرتين بتهمة الاحتيال، وفي حبسها الثاني ظلت ١٠ أشهر
وبعد خروجها، كان منزلها قد تهدم بفعل الزلزال،
فعوضتها الحكومة بالمال فاشترت بيتا في بلدة كوريجو شمال إيطاليا
وافتتحت لها دكانا لبيع الخردوات.
واشتهرت جنجولي بكونها امرأة طيبة تساعد الناس وتجيد قراءة الطالع
والوصفات السحرية، فهم لم يكونوا يعرفون ماضيها،
وكانت تحب أبناءها حبا شديدا،
وكان الناس يخافون أن يتعرض أبناؤها للضرب
فسيتلقون العقوبات من أمهم التي ستفعل المستحيل من أجل أبنائها،
وعند دخول أيطاليا في الحرب العالمية الثانية
كان التجنيد إجباريا حينها فخافت أن يأخذوا ابنها الأكبر جوزيف،
فتذكرت لعنة أمها، وبدأت تفكر بتقديم قرابين بشرية لتفدي بهم أبناءها،
وبدأت جنجولي بتقديم ضحيتها الأولى،
وكانت تدعى (الآنسة فوستينا سيتي)
وكانت من النساء اللواتي يترددن عليها، فقطعتها إلى أجزاء صغيرة،
ثم اختارت أرملة تدعى (فرانشيسكا سوافي)
قالت لها جنجولي أنها تعرف الكثير من المسؤولين النافذين
وستعطيها وظيفة في مدرسة للبنات، وكانت جنجولي محل ثقة
من سكان البلدة فصدقتها المرأة، وقالت لها
عليك أن تحضري ملابسك التي تحتاجينها وتجمعي جميع أموالك ومجوهراتك
وأن تأتي إلي فجر اليوم الذي ستغادرين به إلى بلدة الوظيفة،
ولا تخبري أحدا بذلك، ففعلت ذلك ولقيت حتفها،
وعندما قتلتها جنجولي أذابت عظامها في ماء مغلي وأضافت
عليه الصودا لتصنع منه الصابون الذي تبيعه في دكانها،
أما آخر ضحاياها فكانت السيدة (فرجينا كاجوبو)،
التي كانت جميلة جدا فهي كانت مغنية مشهورة آنذاك
إلا أن تقدمها بالعمر جعلها تفقد معظم أعمالها،
فجاءت إلى جنجولي لتجد لها حلا لمشكلتها،
فوعدتها جنجولي بأنها ستوفر لها وظيفة كسكرتيرة
لأحد أكبر مدراء المسارح في المدينة،
وبذلك ستعود المغنية للأضواء مجددا،
وكعادتها طلبت منها أن يبقى الأمر سرا وأنت تحضر القليل من الملابس
وكل ما تدخره من أموال ومجوهرات، فانتهى الأمر بالمغنية
حيث انتهى بسابقتيها،
نهاية مجرمة
كانت زوجة شقيقة المغنية تبحث عنها ولما غابت لعدة أسابيع
أبلغت الشرطة، وقالت أن المغنية أخذت ملابسها ومدخراتها
عند فجر ذات يوم ولم تعد إلى حد إبلاغها للشرطة،
وعند التحقيق أخبرتهم أن المغنية كانت تتردد على امرأة كاهنة تدعى جنجولي،
فذهبت الشرطة إلى دكان جنجولي،
وحققوا معها، فأنكرت كل شيء،
فهددوها باتهام ابنها باختطاف المغنية وضغطوا عليها،
فخارت قواها واعترفت بكل جرائمها،
وأنها كانت تذيب أجساد ضحايها بالماء المغلي والصودا،
وتصنع منها الصابون، وما تبقى من عظام الأجساد
كانت ترميه في البالوعة، وقالت لهم أن كل عملية لم تأخذ منها
سوى ١٢ دقيقة، فأعطوها سكينا وجثة لتثبت صدقها ففعلت،
فتمت محاكمتها وكانت قضيتها قضية الرأي العام الأكبر حينها في إيطاليا،
ودافعت عن نفسها بأنها كانت تقوم بذلك دفاعا عن أبنائها،
فحكم عليها بالسجن ٣٣ عاما،  تقضي٣منها في المصحة العقلية،
وتحققت رؤيا منجمة كانت قد أخبرتها أنها ستقضي نصف آخر سنواتها
في المستشفى والنصف الآخر في غرفة محكمة الإغلاق
فكان ذلك هو السجن،
لكنها ماتت في سجنها عام١٩٧٠ بعد مضي ٢٤ عاما،
وقالت إحدى زميلاتها في السجن،
على الرغم من تشوقنا لأكل الحلويات والكعك الذي كانت تصنعه جنجولي
في السجن فقد كان لا يقاوم، إلا أننا كنا نخاف أن تصنع لنا السحر والشعوذات
بداخله، لذا فقد كانت تعود وتأكلها بنفسها،.
برأيكم مشاهدينا لماذا أصبحت جنجولي مجرمة لهذا الحد؟...